today I want to do two things I want to
finish the discussion of zookeeper and
then talk about crack the particular
things that I'm most interested in
talking about a bad zookeeper are the
design of its API that allows the
zookeeper to be a general-purpose
service that really bites off
significant tasks that distributed
systems need so why is this you know why
is that a good API design and then the
really more specific topic of mini
transactions turns out this is a
worthwhile idea to know so they got API
and I'm just just a recall zookeepers
based on raft and so we can think of it
as being and indeed it is fault tolerant
and does the right thing with respect to
partitions it has this sort of
performance enhancement by which reads
can be processed at any replica and
therefore the reads can be stale so we
just have to keep this in mind as we're
analyzing various uses of the zookeeper
interface on the other hand zookeeper
does guarantee that every replicas
process the stream of rights in order
one at a time with all replicas
executing the rights in the same order
so that the replicas advance sort of in
their states of all than exactly the
same way and that all of the operation
reads and writes produced by a generated
by a single client or processed by the
system also in order both in the order
that the client issued them in and
successive operations from a given
client always see the same state or
later in the right stream as the
previous read operation right any
operation from that client okay so
before I dive into what the API looks
like and why it's useful it's worth just
thinking about what kinds of problems
zookeeper is aiming to solve or could be
expected to solve so
for me
a totally central example of motivation
of why you would want to use ooh keeper
this is it as an implementation of the
test and set service that vmware ft
required in order for either server to
take over when the other one failed it
was a bit of a mystery in the vmware
paper
what is this test instant service how is
it may you know is it fault tolerant
does it itself tolerate partitions but
zookeeper actually gives us the tools to
write a fault tolerant test and set
service of exactly the kind that vmware
ft needed that is fault tolerant and
does do the right thing under partitions
that's sort of a central kind of thing
that zookeepers doing there's also a
bunch of other ways that turns out
people use it suki was very successful
people use it for a lot of stuff one
kind of thing people use is just to
publish just configuration information
for other servers to use like for
example the IP address of the current
master for some set of workers this is
just config configuration information
another classic use of zookeepers to
elect a master you know if we want to
have a when the old master fails we need
to have everyone agree on who the new
master is and only elect one master even
if there's partitions you can elect a
master using zookeeper primitives if the
master for small amounts of stated
anyway if whatever master you elect
needs to keep some state it needs to
keep it up-to-date like maybe you know
informations such as who the primary is
for a given chunk of data like you'd
want in GFS the master can store its
state in zookeeper it knows new keepers
not going to lose it if the master
crashes and we elect a new master to
replace it that new master can just read
the old master state right out of
zookeeper and rely on it actually being
there
other things you might imagine maybe you
know MapReduce like systems workers
could register themselves by creating
little files and zookeeper and again
with systems like MapReduce you can
imagine the master telling the workers
what to do by writing things in
zookeeper like writing lists of work in
zookeeper and then worker sort of take
those work items one by one out of
zookeeper and delete them as they
complete them but people use zookeeper
for all these things question
yeah
exactly yeah so the question is oh how
people use zookeeper and in generally
yeah you you would if you're running
some big data center and you run all
kinds of stuff in your data center you
know web servers storage systems
MapReduce who knows what you might fire
up a zookeeper one zookeeper cluster
because this general purpose can be used
for lots of things so you know five or
seven zookeeper replicas and then as you
deploy various services you would design
the services to store some of the
critical state in your one zookeeper
cluster alright the API zookeeper looks
like a filesystem some levels it's got a
directory hierarchy you know there's a
root directory and then maybe you could
maybe each application has its own sub
directory so maybe the application one
keeps its files here in this directory
app two keeps its files in this
directory and you know these directories
have files and directories underneath
them
one reason for this is just because you
keeper is like just mentioned is a
design to be shared between many
possibly unrelated activities we just
need a naming system to be able to keep
the information from these activities
distinct so they don't get confused and
read each other's data by mistake
within each application it turns out
that a lot of convenient ways of using
zookeeper will involve creating multiple
files let's see a couple examples like
this in a few minutes okay so it looks
like a filesystem this is you know not
very deep it doesn't it's not actually
you know you can't really use it like a
file system in the sense of mounting it
and running LS and cat and all those
things it's just that internally it
names objects with these path names so
you know one this x y&z here few
different files you know when you talk
to me you send an RPC - zookeeper saying
you know please read this data you would
name the data you want maybe add up to
slash X there's just a sort of
hierarchical naming scheme these these
files and directories are called Z nodes
and it turns out it's there's three
types you have to know about that helps
you keep or solve various problems for
us there's just regular Z nodes where if
you create one it's permanent until you
delete it there's a femoral Z nodes
where if a client creates an ephemeral Z
node zookeeper will delete that
ephemeral Z node if it believes that the
client has died it's actually tied to
client sessions so clients have to sort
of send a little heartbeat in every once
a while into the zookeeper into
zookeeper say oh I'm still alive I'm
still alive so zookeeper won't delete
their ephemeral files and the last
characteristic files may have is
sequential and that means when you ask
to create a file with a given name what
you actually end up creating is a file
with that name but with a number
appended to the main and zookeeper
guarantees never to repeat a number if
multiple clients try to create
sequential files at the same time and
also to always use montt increasing
numbers for the for the sequence numbers
that are pens to filenames and we'll see
all of these things come up in examples
at one level the operations the RPC
interface that zookeeper exposes is sort
of what you might expect for your files
was to create RPC where you give it a
name really a full path name some
initial data and some combination of
these flags and interesting semantics of
create is that it's exclusive that is
when I send a create into zookeeper ask
it to create a file so you keep your
responds with a yes or no if that file
didn't exist and I'm the first client
who wants to create it zookeeper says
yes and creates the file the file
already exists zookeeper says no or
returns an error so clients know it's
exclusive create and clients know
whether they were the one client if
multiple clients are trying to create
the same file which we'll see in locking
samples
the clients will know whether they were
the one who actually managed to create
the file
there's also delete and one thing I
didn't mention is ever easy note has a
version as a current version number that
advances as its modified and delete
along with some other update operations
you can send an a version number saying
only do this operation if the files
current version number is the version
that was specified and that'll turn out
to be helpful if you're worried about in
situations where multiple clients might
be trying to do the same operation at
the same time so you can pass a version
saying only delete there's an exists
call oh does this path named Xenu exist
an interesting extra argument is that
you can ask to watch for changes to
whatever path name you specified you can
say does this path name exist and
whether or not exists it exists now if
you set this watch if you pass in true
for this watch flag zookeeper guarantees
to notify the client if anything changes
about that path name like it's created
or deleted or modified and furthermore
the the check for whether the file
exists and the setting of the watch
point of the watching information in the
inside zookeeper or atomic so nothing
can happen between the point at which
the point in the write stream which
zookeeper looks to see whether the path
exists and the point in the write stream
at which zookeeper inserts the watch
into its table and then that's like very
important for for correctness we also
get D then you get a path and again the
watch flag and now the watch just
applies to the contents of that file
there's set data
again path the new data and this
conditional version that if you pass an
inversion then zookeeper only actually
does the right if the current version
number of the file is equal to the
number you passed in okay so let's see
how we use this the first maybe almost
this first very simple example is
supposing we have a file in zookeeper
and we want to store a number in that
file and we want to be able to increment
that number so we're keeping maybe a
statistics count and whenever a client
you know I know gets a request from a
web user or something it's going to
increment that count in zookeeper and
more than one client may want to
increment the count that's the critical
thing so an example so one thing to sort
of get out of the way is whether we
actually need some specialized interface
in order to support client coordination
as opposed to just data this looks like
a file system could we just provide the
ordinary readwrite kind of file system
stuff that dated that typical storage
systems provide so for example some of
you have started and you'll all start
soon Ladd 3 in which you build a key
value store where the two operations are
the only operations are put key value
and so one question is can we do you
know all these things that we might want
to do with zookeeper can we just do them
with lab 3 with a key with a key value
put get interface so supposing for my I
want to implement this count thing maybe
I could implement the count with just
lab threes key value interface so you
might increment the count by saying x
equals get you know whatever key were
using and then put that key an X plus 1
why why is this a bad answer yes yes oh
it's not atomic that is absolutely the
root of the problem here and you know
the abstract way of putting it but one
way of looking at it is that of two
clients both want to increment the
counter at the same time they're both
gonna read they're both gonna use get to
read the old value and get you know ten
those gonna add one to ten and get 11
and I was gonna call put with 11 so now
we've increased the counter by one but
two clients were doing it so surely we
should have ended up increasing it by
two so that's why the lab three cannot
be used for even this simple example
furthermore in the sort of zookeeper
world where guests can return stale data
is not lab 3 or gets are not allowed to
return stale data but in zookeeper reads
can be stale and so if you read a stale
version of the current counter and add
one to it
you're now writing the wrong value you
know if 30 values 11 but you're get
returns a stale value of 10 you add 1 to
that and put 11 that's a mistake because
we really should have been putting 12 so
zookeeper has this additional problem
that we have to worry about that
that gets don't return the latest data
ok so how would you do this in zookeeper
here's how I would do this in zookeeper
it turns out you need to do you need to
wrap this code Siemens in a loop because
it's not guaranteed to succeed the first
time so we're just gonna say while true
we're gonna call get data to get the
current value of the counter and the
current version so we're gonna say X V
equals I'm get data and we need to say
final name I don't care what the file
name is we just say that nice now we get
the well we get a value and a version
number possibly not fresh possibly stale
but maybe fresh and then we're gonna use
a conditional put a conditional setting
and if set data is a set data operation
return true meaning it actually did set
the value we're gonna break otherwise
just go back to the top of the loop
otherwise so what's going on here is
that we read some value and some version
number maybe still maybe fresh out of
the replicas the set data we send
actually did the zookeeper leader
because all rights go to the leader and
what this means is only set the value to
X plus one if the version with the real
version the latest version is still is V
so if we read fresh data and nothing
else is going on in the system like no
other clients are trying to increment
this then we'll read the latest version
latest value we'll add one to the latest
value specify the latest version and our
set data will be accepted by the leader
and we'll get back a positive reply to
our request after it's committed and
we'll break because we're done if we got
stale data here or this was fresh data
but by the time
our set data got to the leader some
other clients set data and some other
client is trying to increment their set
data got there before us our version
number will no longer be fresh in either
those cases this set data will fail and
we'll get an error response back it
won't break out of the loop and we'll go
back and try again and hopefully we'll
succeed this time yes yes so the
question is could this it's a while loop
or we guaranteed is ever going to finish
and no no we're not really guaranteed
that we're gonna finish in practice you
know so for example if our replicas were
reading from is cut off from the leader
and permanently gives us stale data then
you know maybe this is not gonna work
out but you know but in real life well
in real life the you know leaders
pushing all the replicas towards having
identical data to the leader so you know
if we just got stale data here probably
when we go back you know maybe we should
sleep for 10 milliseconds or something
at this point but when we go back here
eventually we're gonna see the latest
data the situation under which this
might genuinely be pretty bad news is if
there's a very high continuous load of
increments from clients you know if we
have a thousand clients all trying to do
increments the risk is that maybe none
of them will succeed or something I
think one of them will succeed because I
think one of the most succeed because
you know the the first one that gets its
set data into the leader will succeed
and the rest will all fail because their
version numbers are all too low and then
the next 999 will put and get data's in
and one of them will succeed so it all
have a sort of N squared complexity to
get through all of the all other clients
which is very damaging but it will
finish eventually and so if you thought
you were gonna have a lot of clients you
would use a different strategy here this
is good
or load situations yes if they fit in
memory it's no problem if they don't fit
memory it's a disaster so yeah when
you're using zookeeper you have to keep
in mind that it's yeah it's great for
100 megabytes of stuff and probably
terrible for 100 gigabytes of stuff so
that's why people think of it as storing
configuration information rather than
their we old data of your big website
yes I mean it's sort of watch into this
sequence
yet that could be so if we want if we
wanted to fix this to work under high
load then you would certainly want to
sleep at this point where I'm not well
the way I would fix this my instinct I'm
fixing this would be to insert asleep
here and furthermore double the amount
of it sort of randomized sleep whose
span of randomness doubles each time we
fail and that's a sort of tried and true
strategies exponential back-off is a
it's actually similar to raft leader
election it's a reasonable strategy for
adapting to an unknown number of
concurrent clients so okay tell me
what's right okay so we're getting data
and then watching its true
so yes so if somebody else modifies the
data before you call set data maybe
you'll get a watch notification um the
problem is the timing is not working in
your favor like the amount of time
between when I received the data here
and when I send off the message to the
leader with this new set data is zero
that's how much time will pass here
roughly and if some other client is sent
in increment at about this time it's
actually quite a long time between when
that client sends in the increment and
when it works its way through the leader
and is sent out to the followers and
actually executed the followers and the
followers look it up in their watch
table and send me a notification so I
think
it won't give you any read result or if
you read at a point if you're gonna read
at a point that's after where the
modification occurred that should raise
the watch you'll get the notification of
the watch before you get the read
response but in any case I think nothing
like this could save us because what's
gonna happen is all thousand clients are
gonna do the same thing whatever it is
right they're all gonna do again and set
a watch and whatever they're all gonna
get the notification at the same time
they're all gonna make the same decision
about well they're all not gonna get to
watch because none of them has done the
put data yet right
so the worst case is all the clients are
starting at the same point they all do a
get they all get version one they all
set a watch point they don't get a
notification because no change has
occurred they all send a set data RPC to
the leader all thousand of them the
first one changes the data and now the
other 999 and get a notification when
it's too late because they've already
sent the set data so it's possible that
watch could help us here but sort of
straightforward version of watch I have
a feeling if you wanted the the mail
we'll talk about this in a few minutes
but the anon heard the second locking
example absolutely solves this kind of
problem so we could adapt to the second
locking example from the paper to try to
cause the increments to happen one at a
time if there's a huge number of clients
who want to do it other questions about
this example okay this is an example of
a what many people call a mini
transaction all right it's transactional
in a sense that wow there's you know a
lot of funny stuff happening here the
effect is that once it all succeeds we
have achieved an atomic
read-modify-write of the counter right
the difficulty here
is that it's not atomic the reading the
right the read the modifying the right
are not atomic the thing that we have
pulled off here is that this sequence
once it finishes is atomic right we
actually man and once we have to be on
the pass through this that we succeeded
we managed to read increment and write
without anything else intervening we
managed to do these two steps atomically
and you know this is not because this
isn't a full database transaction like
real databases allow fully general
transactions where you can say start
transaction and then read or write
anything you like maybe thousands of
different data items whatever who knows
what and then say end transaction and
the database will cleverly commit the
whole thing as an atomic transaction so
real transactions can be very
complicated zookeeper supports this
extremely simplified version of you know
when you're sort of one we can do it
atomic sort of operations on one piece
of data but it's enough to get increment
and some other things so these are for
that reason since they're not general
but they do provide atomicity these are
often called mini transactions and it
turns out this pattern can be made to
work with various other things too like
if we wanted to do the test and set that
vmware ft requires it can be implemented
with very much this setup you know maybe
the old value if it's zero then we try
to set it to one but give this version
number you know nobody else intervened
and we were the one who actually managed
to set it to one because the version
number hadn't changed but i'm leader got
our request and we win somebody else
changes to one after we read it then the
leader will tell us that we lost so you
can do test and set with this pattern
also and you should remember this is the
strategy
okay alright next example I want to talk
about is these locks and I'm talking
about this because it's in the paper not
because I strongly believe that this
kind of lock is useful but they have
they have an example in which a choir
has a couple steps one we try to create
we have a lock file and we try to create
the lock file now again some file with a
femoral set to true and so if that
succeeds then or not we've acquired the
lock the second step that doesn't
succeed then we want to wait for whoever
did acquire the lock what if this isn't
true that means the lock file already
exists I mean somebody else has acquired
the lock and so we want to wait for them
to release the lock and they're gonna
release the lock by deleting this file
so we're gonna watch yes
alright so we're gonna watch we're gonna
gonna call exists and watching is true
now it turns out that um okay and and
and if the file still exists right which
we expect it to because after all they
didn't exist presumably would have
returned here so if it exists we want to
wait for the notification we're waiting
for this watch notification call this
three and a step for go to what so the
usual deal is you know we call create
you know maybe we win if it fails we
wait for whoever owns a lock to release
it we get the watch notification when
the file is deleted at that point this
wait finishes and we go back to Mon and
try to recreate the file hopefully we
will get the file this time okay so we
should ask ourselves questions about
possible interleavings of other clients
activities with our four steps so one we
know for sure we know of already if
another client calls create at the same
time then the zookeeper leader is going
to process those two to create rpcs one
at a time in some order
so either mike reid will be executed
first
or the other clients create will be
executed first minds executed first i'm
going to get a true back in return and
acquire the lock and the other client is
guaranteed to get a false return and if
there are pcs processed first they'll
get the true return and i'm guaranteed
to get the false return and in either
case the file will be created
so we're okay if we have simultaneous
executions of one another question is
well you know if I if create doesn't
succeed for me and I'm gonna call exists
what happens if the lock is released
actually between the create and the
exists
so this is the reason why I rap I have a
knife around me around the exists is
because it actually might be released
before I call exists because it could
have been acquired quite a long time ago
by some other client and then if the
file doesn't exist at this point then
this will fail and I'll just go directly
back to this go to one and try again
similarly and actually more interesting
is what happens if the whoever holds it
now releases it just as I call exist or
as the replica I'm talking to is in the
middle of processing my exists requests
and the answer to that is that the
whatever replica I'm looking at you know
it's log or guaranteed that rights occur
in some order right
so the repla I'm talking to it's it's
log its proceeding in some way and my
exists call is guaranteed to be executed
between two log entries in the right
stream right this is a this is a
read-only request and you know the
problem is that somebody's delete
request is being processed at about this
time so somewhere in the log is going
either is going to be the delete request
from the other client and the rep and
you know this is my mind the replica
that I'm talking to zookeeper replicas
I'm talking to his log my watch my
exists RPC is either processed
completely processed here in which case
the replica sees oh the file still
exists and the replica inserts the watch
information into its watch table at this
point and only then executes the delete
so when the delete comes in were
guaranteed that my watch request is in
the replicas watch table and it will
send me a notification right or my exist
requests is executed here at a point
after the delete happen the file doesn't
exist and so now the call returns true
and
no well actually a watch table entry is
entered but we don't care right so it's
quite important that the rights are
sequenced and that reads happen at
definite points between rights yes well
okay so yes so this is where the exists
is executed the file doesn't exist at
this point exists returns false we don't
wait we go to one we create the file and
return we did install a watch here that
watch will be triggered it doesn't
really matter because we're not really
waiting for it but the watch will be
triggered by this created
we're not waiting for it but yeah okay
so the file doesn't exist we go to one
somebody else has created the file we
try to create the file that fails we
install another watch and it's a dis
watch that we're not waiting for so this
way does not a wait for anything to
happen although it doesn't really matter
in the moment it's not harmful to to to
break out of this loop early it's just
wasteful anyway we've all the history
this code leaves watches sort of in the
system and I don't really know what does
my new watch on the same file override
my old watch I'm not actually sure
okay I'm finally this example and the
previous example suffle suffer from the
herd effect we also heard effect we
talked about I mean what we were talking
about when we were worrying about oh but
if clients I'll try to increment this at
the same time
gosh that's going to have N squared
complexity as far as how long it takes
to get to all thousand clients this lock
scheme also suffers from the herd effect
in that if there are a thousand clients
trying to get the lock then the amount
of time that's required to sort of grant
the lock to each one of the thousand
clients is proportional to a thousand
squared because after every release all
of the remaining clients get triggered
by this watch all of the remaining
clients go back up here and send in a
create and so the total number create
our pcs generated is basically a
thousand squared so this suffers from
this herd the whole herd of waiting
clients is beating on zookeeper another
name for this is that it's a non
scalable lock or yeah okay and so the
paper is a real deal and we'll see it
more and in other systems and soon
enough serious end of problems the paper
actually talks about how to solve it
using zookeeper and the interesting
thing is that Zook
it's actually expressive enough to be
able to build a more complex lock scheme
that doesn't suffer from this hurt
effect that even of a thousand clients
are waiting the cost of one client
giving up a lock and another acquiring
it is order 1 instead of order n and
this is the because it's a little bit
complex this is the pseudocode in the
paper in section 2.4 it's on page 6 if
you want to follow along so this is and
so this time there is not a single lock
file
there's no yes it is just a name that
allows us to all talk about the same
lock so it's just a name know now I've
acquired the lock and I can do I can
whatever the lock was protecting you
know maybe only one of us at a time
should be allowed to give a lecture in
this lecture hall if you want to give a
lecture in this lecture hall you first
have to acquire the lock called 34 100
the that turns out it's yes it's a Z
node and zookeeper but it like nobody
cares about its contents we just need it
to be able to agree on a name for the
lock that's the sense in which that's
piyah this it looks like a file system
but it's really a naming system alright
so step one is we create a sequential
file
and so yeah we give it a prefix name but
what it actually creates is you know if
this is the 27th file sequential file
created with with prefix F you know
maybe we get F 27 or something and and
in the sequenced in the sequence of
writes that zookeeper is it's working
through successive creates get ascending
guaranteed ascending never descending
always ascending sequence numbers when
you create a sequential file there was
an operation I left off from the list it
turns out you can get a list of files
you can get a list of files underneath
you give the name of Zeno that's
actually a directory with files in it
you can get a list of all the files that
are currently in that directory so we're
gonna list the files let's start with
that you know maybe list f star we get
some list back we create a file with the
system allocated us a number here we can
look at that number if there's no lower
numbered file in this list then we win
and we get the lock
so if our sequential file is the lowest
number file with that name prefix we win
so no lower number we've quired the lock
and we can return if there is one then
again what we want to wait for then
what's going on is that these
sequentially numbered files are setting
up the order in which the lock is going
to be granted to the different clients
so if we're not the winner of the lock
what we need to do is wait for the
previously numbered with the client who
created the previously numbered file to
release to acquire and then release the
lock and we're going to release the lock
the convention for releasing the locking
in this system is for
remove the file to remove your
sequential file so we want to wait for
the previously numbered sequential file
to be deleted and then it's our turn and
we get the lock so we need to call
exists so we're gonna say if the call
exists mostly to set a watch point
so it's you know next lower number file
and we want to have a watch get that
file still exist we're gonna wait and
then so that's step 5
and then finally we're gonna go back to
we're not going to create the file again
because it already exists we're gonna go
back to listing the yeah the files so
this is a choir releases just I delete
if I acquire the lock I delete my the
file I created complete with my number
yes
why do you need to list the files again
that's a good question so the question
is we got the list of files we know the
next lower number file there's a
guarantee of the sequential file
creation is that once filed 27 is
created no file with a lower number will
ever subsequently be created so we now
know nothing else could sneak in here so
how could the next lower number file you
know why why do we need to list again
why don't we just go back to waiting for
that same lower numbered file thing
Britney guess the answer
I mean the the the way this code works
the answer to the question is whoever
was the next lowered person might have
either acquired him at least the lock
before we noticed or have died and this
went and these are transient files sorry
or whatever they're called ephemeral
there's an ephemeral file you know even
if we're 27th in line number 26 may have
died before getting the lock if number
26 dies the system automatically deletes
their ephemeral files and so if that
happened now we need to wait for number
25 that is the next you know it if all
files you know 2 through 27 and and
we're 27 if they're all they are and
they're all waiting there's a lock if if
the one before is dies before getting
the lock now we need to wait for the
next next lower number file not because
the next lower one is has gone away so
that's why we have to go back and relist
the files in case our predecessor in the
list of waiting clients turned out to
die yes
if there's no lower numbered file than
you have acquired the lock absolutely
yes how does this not suffer from the
herd effect suppose we have a thousand
clients waiting and currently client
made through the first five hundred and
client five hundred holds the lock every
client waiting every client is sitting
here waiting for an event but only the
client that created file five hundred
and one he's waiting for the vision of
file five hundred so everybody's waiting
for the next lower number so five
hundred is waiting for 499 twenty nine
nine but everybody everybody's waiting
for just one file when I release the
lock there's only one other client the
next higher numbered client that's
waiting for my file so when I release
the lock one client gets a notification
one client goes back and lists the files
one client and one client now has the
lock so the sort of expense you know no
matter how many clients that are the
expense of one of each release and
acquire is a constant number of our PCs
where's the expense of a release and
acquire here is that every single
waiting client is notified and every
single one of them sends a write request
than the create request into zookeeper
oh you're free to get a cup of coffee
yeah I mean this is you know what the
programming interface looks like is not
our business but this is either and
there's there's two options for what
this actually means as far as what the
program looks like one is there's some
thread that's actually in a synchronous
wait it's made a function call saying
please acquire this lock and the
function hold doesn't return until the
locks finally acquired or the
notification comes back of much more
sophisticated interface would being one
in which you fire off requests a
zookeeper and don't wait and then
separately there's some way of seeing
well as you keep your said anything
recently or I have some go routine whose
job it is just wait for the next
whatever it is from zookeeper in the
same sense that you might read the apply
Channel and just all kinds of
interesting stuff comes up on the apply
channel so that's a more likely way to
structure this but yeah you're totally
either through threading or some sort of
event-driven thing you can do something
else while you're waiting yes yes or if
the person before me has neither died
nor released it's a file before me
exists that means either that client is
still alive and still waiting for the
lock or still alive and holds the lock
we don't really know
it does it as long as that client 500
still live if if this exists fails that
means one of two things either my
predecessor held the lock and is
released it and deleted their file or my
predecessor didn't hold the lock they
exited and zookeeper deleted their file
because it was an ephemeral file so
there's two reasons to come out of this
to come out of his weight or four they
exist to return false and that's why we
have to like we check everything you
know you really don't know what the
situation is after the exists completes
that might that yeah maybe maybe that
could need to work that sounds
reasonable
and it preserves the sort of scalable
nature of this and that each require
release only involves a few clients two
clients
alright this pattern to me actually
first saw this pattern a totally
different context and scalable locks for
threading systems I go this end in for
most of the world this is called a scale
of a lock
I find it one of those interesting
constructions I've ever seen now and so
like I'm impressed that zookeeper is
able to express it and it's a valuable
construct having said that I'm a little
bit at sea about why zookeeper about why
the paper talks about locks at all
because these locks these locks are not
like threading locks and go because in
threading there's no notion of threads
failing at least if you don't want them
there to be there's no notions of
threads just sort of randomly dying and
go and so really the only thing you're
getting out of a mutex it's really the
case and go that when you use it if
everybody uses mutexes correctly you are
getting atomicity for the sequence of
operations inside the mutex that you
know if you take out a lock and go and
you do 47 different read and write a lot
of variables and then release the lock
if everybody follows that locking
strategy nobody's ever going to see some
sort of weird intermediate version of
the data as of halfway through you're
updating it right just makes things
atomic no argument these locks aren't
really like that because if the client
that holds the lock fails it just
releases the lock and somebody else can
pick up the lock so it does not
guarantee atomicity because you can get
partial failures and distributed systems
where you don't really get partial
failures of ordinary threaded code so if
the current lock holder had the lock and
needed to update a whole bunch of things
that were protected by that lock before
releasing and only got halfway through
updating this stuff and then crashed
then the lock will get released you'll
get the lock and yet when you go to look
at the data it's garbage because it's
just whatever random seed it was in the
middle of
updated so there's these locks don't by
themselves provide the same atomicity
guarantee that threading locks do and so
we're sort of left to imagine for
ourselves by the paper or why you would
want to use them or why this is the sort
of some of the main examples in the
paper so I think if you use locks like
this then you sort in a distributed
system then you have two general options
one is everybody who acquires a lock has
to be prepared to clean up from some
previous disaster right so you acquire
this lock you look at the data you try
to figure out gosh if the previous owner
of a lot crashed
you know when I'm looking at the data
you know how can I fix the data to make
up how can I decide if the previous
owner crashed and what do I do to fix up
the data and you can play that game
especially if the convention is that you
always update in a particular sequence
you may be able to detect where in that
sequence the previous holder crashed
assuming they crashed but it's a you
know it's a tricky game the requires
thought of a kind you don't need for
like thread locking um the other reason
maybe these locks would make sense is if
there's sort of soft locks protecting
something that doesn't really matter
so for example if you're running
MapReduce jobs map tasks reduce tasks
you could use this kind of lock to make
sure only one task only one worker
executed each task so workers gonna run
test 37 it gets the lock for task 37
execute it marks it as executed and
releases it well the way not produce
works it's actually proof against
crashed workers anyway so if you grab a
lock and you crash halfway through your
MapReduce job so what the next person
who gets the lock you know because your
lock will be released when you crash the
next version who gets it will see you
didn't finish the task and just we
execute it and it's just not a problem
because of the way MapReduce is defined
so you could use these locks or some
kind of soft lock thing although anyway
and you know maybe the other thing which
we should be thinking about is that some
version of this
be used to do things like elect a master
but if what we're really doing here is
electing a master you know we could use
code much like this and that would
probably be a reasonable approach yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah so the picking of
paper talk that remember the text in the
paper were says it's going to delete the
ready file and then do a bunch of
updates to files and then recreate the
ready file that would that is a
fantastic way of sort of detecting and
coping with the possibility that the
previous lock held or the previous
master or whoever it is crashed halfway
through because gosh the ready file has
never be created
Inigo program yeah sadly that is
possible and you know either okay so the
question is nothing about zookeeper but
if you're writing threaded code and go a
thread acquires a lock could it crash
while holding the lock halfway through
whatever stuff it's supposed to be doing
while holding a lock and the answer is
yes actually there are there are ways
for an individual thread to crash and go
oh I forget where they are maybe divide
by zero certain panics anyway you can do
it and my advice about how to think
about that is that the program is now
broken and you've got to kill it because
in threaded code the way the thing about
locks is that while the lock is held the
invariants in the data don't hold so
there's no way to proceed if the lock
holder crashes there's no safe way to
proceed because all you know is whatever
the invariants were that the lock was
protecting no longer hold so and so and
if you do want to proceed you have to
leave the lock marked as held so that no
one else will ever be able to acquire it
and you know unless you have some clever
idea that's pretty much the way you have
to think about it in a threaded program
because that's kind of the style with
which people write threaded lock
programs if you're super clever you
could play the same kinds of tricks like
this ready flag trick now it's super
hard and go because the memory model
says there is nothing you can count on
except if there's a happens before
relationship so if you play this game of
writing changing some variables and then
setting a done flag that doesn't mean
anything unless you release a lock and
somebody else acquires a lock and only
then can anything be said about the
order in which or in even whether the
updates happen so this is very very hard
it rivairy hard and go to recover from a
crash of a thread that holds the lock
here is maybe a little more possible
okay okay okay that's all I want to talk
about with zoo keeper
it's just two pieces of high bid one is
at these clever ideas for high
performance by reading from any replica
but the they sacrifice a bit of
consistency and the other interesting
thing uninteresting take-home is that
they worked out this API that really
does let them be a general-purpose sort
of coordination service in a way that
simpler schemes like put get interfaces
just can't do so they worked out a set
of functions here that allows you to do
things like write mini transactions and
build your own locks and it all works
out although requires care okay now I
want to turn to today's paper which is
crack the the reason why we're reading a
crack paper it's a couple reasons one is
is that it's it does replication for
fault tolerance and as we'll see the
properties you get out of crack or its
predecessor chain replication are very
different in interesting ways from the
properties you get out of a system like
raft and so I'm actually going to talk
about so crack is sort of an
optimization to an older scheme called
chain replication chain replications
actually fairly frequently used in the
real world there's a bunch of systems
that use it
crack is an optimization to it that
actually does a similar trick -
zookeeper where it's trying to increase
weed throughput by allowing reads to two
replicas to any replicas so that you get
you know number of replicas factor of
increase in the read performance the
interesting thing about crack is that it
does that while preserving
linearise ability
unlike zookeeper which you know it
seemed like in order to be able to read
from any replica they had to sacrifice
freshness and therefore snot
linearizable crack actually manages to
do these reads from any replica while
preserving strong consistency I'm just
pretty interesting okay so first I want
to talk about the older system chain
replication teen replication is a it's
just a scheme for you have multiple
copies you want to make sure they all
seen the same sequence of right so it's
like a very familiar basic idea but it's
a different topology then raft so the
idea is that there's a chain of servers
and chain replication and the first one
is called the head last one's called the
tail when a right comes in when a client
wants to write something say some client
it sends always Albright's get sent to
the head the head updates its or
replaces its current copy of the data
that the clients writing so you can
imagine be go put key value store so you
know if everybody started out with you
know version a of the data and under
chain replication when the head process
is the right and maybe we're writing
value B you know the head just replaces
its a with a B and passes the right down
the chain as each node sees the right it
replaces over writes its copy the data
the new data when the right gets the
tail the tail sends the reply back to
the client saying we completed your
right
that's how rights work reads if a client
wants to do a read it sends the read to
the tail the read request of the tail
and the tail just answers out of its
current state so if we ask for this
whatever this object was the tail which
is I hope current values be weeds are a
good deal simpler
okay so it should think for a moment
like why to chain chain replication so
this is not crack just to be clear this
is chain replication chain replication
is linearizable you know in the absence
of failures what's going on is that we
can essentially view it as really than
the purposes of thinking about
consistency it's just this one server
the server sees all the rights and it
sees all the reads and process them one
at a time and you know a read will just
see the latest value that's written and
that's pretty much all there is to it
from the point of view look if there's
no crashes what the consistency is like
pretty simple the failure recovery the a
lot of the rationale behind chain
replication is that the set of states
you can see when after there's a failure
is relatively constrained because of
this very regular pattern with how the
writes get propagated and at a high
level what's going on is that any
committed write that is any rate that
could have been acknowledged to a client
to the writing client or any rate that
could have been exposed in a read
that'll neither of those will ever
happen unless that write reached the
tail in order for it to reach the tail
it had to a pass through them in process
by every single node in the chain so we
know that if we ever exposed to write
ever acknowledged write ever use it to a
read that means every single node in the
tail must know about that right we don't
get these situations like if you'll call
figure seven figure eight and RAF paper
where you can have just hair-raising
complexity and how the different
replicas differ if there's a crash here
you know either that it is committed or
it before the crash should reach some
point and nowhere after that point
because the progress of rights has
always menu so committed rights are
always known everywhere if a right isn't
committed that means that before
whatever crash it was that disturb the
system the rate of got into a certain
point everywhere before that point and
nowhere after
point there's really the only two setups
and at a high level failure recovery is
relatively simple also if the head fails
then to a first approximation the next
node can simply take over his head and
nothing else needs to get done because
any rate that made it as far as the
second node while it was the head that
failed so that right will keep on going
and we'll commit if there's a rate that
made it to the head before a crash but
the head didn't forward it well that's
definitely not committed nobody knows
about it and we definitely didn't send
it an acknowledgment to the writing
client because the write didn't get down
here so we're not obliged to do anything
about a write it only reached a crashed
head before it failed I may be the
client where we sinned but you know not
our problem if the tale fails it's
actually very similar the tale fails the
next node can directly take over because
everything the tale knew then next the
node just before it also knows because
the tale only hears things from the node
just before it and it's a little bit
complex of an intermediate node fails
but basically what needs to be done is
we need to drop it from the chain and
now there may be rights that it had
received that the next node hasn't
received yet and so if we drop a note
out of the chain the predecessor may
need to resend recent rights to the to
its new successor right that's the
recovery in a nutshell that's for why
this construction why this instead of
something else like why this verse is
wrapped for example the performance
reason is that in raft if you recall we
you know if we have a leader and a bunch
of you know some number of replicas
right with the leader it's not in a
chain we got these the replicas are all
directly fed by the leader so if a
client right comes in or a client read
for that matter the the leader has to
send it itself to each of the replicas
whereas in chain replication the leader
on the head only has to do once and
these cents on the network are actually
reasonably expensive and so that means
the load on a raft leader is going to be
higher than the load on a chain
replication leader and so that means
that you know as the number of client
requests per second that you're getting
from clients goes up a raft leader will
hit a limit and stop being able to get
faster sooner than a chain replication
head because it's doing more work than
the chain replication had another
interesting difference between chain
replication and raft is that the reeds
in raft are all also required to be
processed by the leaders the leader sees
every single request from clients
where's here the head sees everybody
sees all the rights but only a tail sees
the reed requests so there may be an
extent to which the load is sort of
split between the head and the tail
rather than concentrated in the leader
and and as I mentioned before the
failure different sort of analysis
required to think about different
failure scenarios is a good deal simpler
and chain replication than it is and
raft and as a big motivation because
it's hard to get this stuff correct yes
yeah so if the tale fails but its
predecessor had seen a right that the
tale hadn't seen then the failure of
that Hale basically commits that right
is now committed because it's reached
the new tale and so he could respond to
the client it probably won't because it
you know it wasn't a tail when it
received the right and so the client may
resend the right and that's too bad and
so we need duplicate suppression
probably at the head basically all the
systems were talking about require in
addition to everything else suppression
of duplicate client requests yes pink
psyche setting in you want to know who
makes the decisions about how to that's
a outstanding question the question is
or rephrase the question a bit if
there's a failure like or suppose the
second node stops being able to talk to
the head can this second node just take
over can it decide for itself gosh the
head seems to thought away I'm gonna
take over his head and tell clients to
talk to me instead of the old head but
what do you think that's not like a plan
with the usual assumptions we make about
how the network behaves that's a recipe
for split brain right if you do exactly
what I said because of course what
really happened was that look the
network failed here the head is totally
alive and the head thinks its successor
has died you know the successors
actually alive it thinks the head has
died and they both say well gosh that
other server seems to have died I'm
gonna take over and the head is gonna
say oh I'll just be a sole replica and I
you know act as the head and the tail
because the rest of the change seems to
have gone away and second I'll do the
same thing and now we have two
independent split brain versions of the
data which will gradually get out of
sync so this construction is not proof
against network partition and has not
does not have a defense against split
brain and what that means in practice is
if it cannot be used by itself it's like
a helpful thing to have in our back
pocket but it's not a complete
replication story so it's it's very
commonly used but it's used in this
stylized way in which there's always an
external Authority you know not not this
chain that decides who's that sort of
makes a call on who's alive and who's
dead and make sure everybody agrees on a
single story about who constitutes the
change there's never any disagreement
some people think the change is this no
and some people think the chain is this
other node so what's that's usually
called as a configuration manager and
its job is just a monitor aliveness and
every time it sees of all the servers
every time Isis every time the
configuration manager thinks the
server's dead it sends out a new
configuration in which you know that
this chain has a new definition had
whatever tail and that's server that the
configuration manager thinks is that may
or may not be dead but we don't care
because everybody is required to follow
then your configuration
and so there can't be any disagreement
because there's only one party making
these decisions not going to disagree
with itself of course how do you make a
service that's fault tolerant and
doesn't disagree with itself but doesn't
suffer from split brain if there's
network partitions and the answer to
that is that the configuration manager
usually uses wrath or paxos or in the
case of crack zookeeper which itself of
course is built on a raft like scheme so
so you to the usual complete set up in
your data center is it you have a
configuration manager it's it's based on
or after PACs or whatever so it's fault
tolerant and does not suffer from split
brain and then you split up your data
over a bunch of change if you know room
with a thousand servers in it and you
have you know chain a you know it's
these servers or the configuration
manager decides that the change should
look like chain a is made of server one
server to server three chain be you know
server for server 5 over 6 whatever and
it tells everybody this whole list it's
all the clients know all the servers
know and the individual servers opinions
about whether other servers are alive or
dead are totally neither here nor there
if this server really does die then then
the head is required to keep trying
indefinitely until I guess a new
configuration from the configuration
manager not allowed to make decisions
about who's alive and who's dead what's
that
oh boy you've got a serious problem so
that's why you replicated using raft
make sure the different replicas are on
different power supplies the whole works
but this this construction I've set up
here it's extremely common and it's how
chain replication is intended to be used
how cracks intend to be used and the
logic of it is that like chain require
replication if you don't have to worry
about partition and split brain you can
build very high speed efficient
replication systems using chain
replication for example so these
individual you know data replication and
we're sharding the data over many chains
individually this these chains can be
built to be just the most efficient
scheme for the particular kind of thing
that you're replicating you may read
heavy right heavy whatever but we don't
have to worry too much about partitions
and then all that worry is concentrated
in the reliable non split-brain
configuration manager
okay so your question is why are we
using chain replication here instead of
raft okay so it's like a totally
reasonable question um the the it
doesn't really matter for this
construction because even if we're using
raft here we still need one party to
make a decision with which there can be
no disagreement about how the data is
divided over our hundred different
replication groups right so all you know
and I need kind of big system you're
splitting your sharding or splitting up
the data
somebody needs to decide how the data is
assigned to the different replication
groups this has to change over time as
you get more or less Hardware more data
or whatever so if nothing else the
configuration manager is saying well
look you know the keys start with a or B
goes here or then C or D goes here even
if you use Paxos here now there's also
this smaller question if we didn't eat
you know what should we use for
replication should be chain replication
or paxos or raft or whatever and people
do different things some people do
actually use Paxos based replication
like spanner which I think we're gonna
look at later in the semester has this
structure but it actually uses Paxos to
replicate rights for the data you know
the reason why you might not want to use
PAC so so raft is that it's arguably
more efficient to use this chain
construction because it reduces the load
on the leader and that may or may not be
a critical issue the a reason to favor
rafter Paxos is that they do not have to
wait for a lagging replica this chain
replication has a performance problem
that if one of these replicas is slow
because even for a moment
you know because every rate has to go
through every replica even a single slow
replica slows down all offer all right
operations and I can be very damaging
you know if you have thousands of
servers probably did any given time you
know seven of them are out to lunch or
unreliable or slow because somebody's
installing new software who knows what
and that so it's a bit damaging to have
every request be sort of limited by the
slowest server whereas brafton paxos
well it's so rad for example if one of
the followers is so it doesn't matter
because that leader only has to wait for
a majority it doesn't have to wait for
all of them you know ultimately they all
have to catch up but raft is much better
resisting transient slowdown and some
Paxos based systems although not really
raft are also good at dealing with the
possibility that the replicas are in
different data centers and maybe far
from each other and because you only
need a majority you don't have to
necessarily wait for acknowledgments
from a distant data center and so that
can also leads people to use paxos raft
like majority schemes rather than chain
replication but this is sort of a it
depends very much on your workload and
what you're trying to achieve but this
overall architecture is in I don't know
if it's Universal but it's extremely
common
like intentional topologies okay the for
a for a network that's not broken the
usual assumption is that all the
computers can talk to each other through
the network for networks that are broken
because somebody stepped on a cable or
some routers misconfigured any crazy
thing can happen
so absolutely due to miss configuration
you can get a situation where you know
these two nodes can talk to the
configuration manager and the
configuration managers think sir they're
up but they can't talk to each other so
yes and and that's a killer for this
right because other configuration
manager thinks that are up they can't
talk to each other boy it's just like
it's a disaster and if you need your
system to be resistant to that then you
need to have a more careful
configuration manager you need logic in
the configuration manager that says gosh
I'm only gonna form a chain out of these
services not only I can talk to that but
they can talk to each other and sort of
explicitly check and I don't know if
that's common I mean I'm gonna guess not
but if you were super careful you'd want
to because even though we talked about
network partition that's like a
abstraction and in reality you can get
any combination of who can talk to who
else and some are may be very damaging
okay I'm gonna wrap up and see you next
week